[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you and
welcome back now before we get to our
last Awards we wanted to take a brief
moment to thank all of tonight's
honorees all of the clip packages
helping explain the amazing winning
technology of this year were infinitely
improved with your collaboration thank
you
so all night we've seen incredible
technology that helps create some of the
stunning images in motion pictures but
along the way to finishing a film there
are notes and comments and revisions hey
it's part of the deal and everyone has
to go through it I mean I never get a
note because my first take is the only
take and that is because it's the best
you're gonna get now back in the olden
days the 90s you used to have you used
to have to physically send out cuts by
courier or worse by the mail then this
internet thing got big and offered a new
way to watch content now plenty of
people came up with ways to distribute
videos of rough cuts but one team set
the groundwork for a comprehensive and
secure way to do it this is the pix
system
Eric ducks Eric Billa felt Craig would
and Paul McReynolds the Academy presents
to you a technical achievement award for
the pick system coming up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
flying down today
I thought just don't let us follow
Photoshop congratulations team for over
15 years serving the exceptional talent
in this industry has been a profound
honor we are humbled and grateful to the
Academy for recognizing our efforts and
for a process that was as comprehensive
as it was enjoyable thank you to our
clients who trust us each day to protect
their creative vision and treat us as
part of the crew thank you to the open
source community whose often
unrecognized but critical efforts make
pix possible yep
Thank You Ren Kleiss Zeon Chafin and
David Fincher whose friendship patience
and talents have had an enduring and
measurable impact on our work and more
importantly in filmmaking
and lastly we'd like to thank Larry
shallot and all of our peers that picks
our friends and our family whose
tireless support allows us to best serve
this industry that we love thank you all
very much thanks to everybody thanks the
Academy for recognizing us for for this
work it's been so exciting for me to see
it get used on the films that I watch
every day and thanks to to this team for
for carrying it forward to Erick Dax for
building picks around this technology
and enabling all of these projects
thanks I'd like to thank Eric Dax for
his leadership and vision as well as all
of our customers in the Academy and I'd
also like to thank my beautiful wife and
two daughters for bringing me so much
joy thank you
as an engineer I live in projects in
code and this is very surreal being
recognized in this way and I appreciate
everything about it from the Academy to
our clients to my wife and everyone
involved in all the work we do and it's
an amazing honor and I appreciate it
very much thank you very much
[Music]